hello hello and welcome to this video
which is opening Q&A 3 yeah um yeah
thanks a lot for the great positive
feedback on this new series I got tons
of questions in video number 2 and also
it seems that I was skipping some of the
questions in the video before that
wasn't winningly I somehow overlooked
them and I think some like two or three
now might have been some are deleted in
the first one so there seems to be a
have been a question about Catalan move
orders and then I kind of remember that
I saw it but then I didn't and well
somehow I that one that went under so if
I'm not answering a question I'm going
to tell you in the video why and
what you could possibly rephrase or be
more precise or something I wouldn't
just ignore a question so if you feel it
can be answered sorry just to put it in
again and I'll try my best I also have
to think about the formative it's a good
idea to do that in the comments in
YouTube because it can be quite
irritating probably like if there are
ten videos there people will post
questions in earlier videos and I try to
disable the comments but then you don't
even see them anymore and this is also
don't it doesn't feel right yeah they
should be visible but I don't think you
can make them make the ones visible that
are there and so block a new one so I
have to think about it so until I have a
great technical solution new questions
just in the latest video like this one
now okay let's get started
I won't manage all the questions I know
that this is not possible that I will do
most of them and then
get some of those questions answered in
a separate video probably number four
and I don't want to wait longer than a
week so I want to make one video a week
at least off of this forward so first
one by I think the jjo in the news of
Indian what are the pros and cons let's
put the nimzo-indian so Indian what are
the pros and cons of castles or c5
versus III and Quincy - okay first of
all the nature of those moves is quite
different against those two white
replies the big difference is that after
Queen c2 c5 white is almost forced to
fight for an advantage by taking every
other move doesn't really help a lot as
e3 is not a great combination for
example black will often take and get
into an IQ P type of position where the
queen is prematurely placed on c2 so
after c5 White is usually capturing and
this is fundamentally different from
castles where for example after a three
which is the most popular move it is
rather difficult to play c5 at all you
can prepare it with d6 or b6 but now you
simply cannot play the move white is
taking so here c5 and castles are two
fundamentally different lines they could
transpose into one another in case of
castles Knight f3 or Bishop g5 and then
c5 is again why it is more or less
forced to take and then you get the same
structure so there are some trans
positions but still there's a
fundamental difference in particularly
after castles a three tanks takes this
is something that is just different to
c5 reform however against III in the
Rubinstein castles and c5 is heavily
transpositional in particular if you
Castle intending
to play c5 d5 stuff next then it can
easily transpose there are however some
move order details the main one is said
after c5 white has replied a g2 which
nowadays is believed to be the most
testing probably where either after
later f3 you have to retreat or give up
the bishop here with while being able to
cancel to capture with the night only
two so basically after c5 92 it's a bit
difficult to retreat your Bishop on that
normal diagonal while after castles 92
if white tries the same you have a
multitude of options where after the
main with d5 you can actually go back so
there is a difference really here in
terms of move orders and in terms of
what you do against in particularly
against 92 there is a difference in my
book by the way I have a recommendation
to Castle here because I want to retreat
the bishop back I don't like to see 5
1992 so much and after Queen c2 I have a
highly different line recommended with
Knight to c6 however I believe that
castles and d5 are perfectly valid and
maybe even objectively a little bit
better ok I hope that helped
the next question is by Richard Bedford
and he asks Yeo he is asking about this
opening the news of each defense with E
5 and first of all I would like to
mention that if you
I mean his he asks for black for the
black site him but I want to mention
that if you are white and somebody plays
knight c6 I recommend to just plain idea
3 I think this is just better wolf then
deform because here he was likely with
his post after 5 and anything else is
probably just better for white and this
is a position that you probably play
anyway so I recommend Knight f3
anyway after default Richard asks about
the most if I've and now he says that he
likes the position
after d5 that I do understand that is an
interesting player you go to g6 and get
this out that makes a lot of sense but
he says that he doesn't like D takes e5
and and after 95 93 it seems difficult
to to equalize or to get to a clear
picture what to play I do agree I looked
at this a little bit and I never did
before and I don't quite see something
great that you can do I mean I'm not
saying you're in terrible shape but I'm
not really happy with blacks play here
something that you can do but it's
probably not your liking is d6 it's
probably the most solid move but after
95 I mean if white does that I'm not
saying that it's best but this is
something that is quite uninspiring
yeah I don't think white has much but so
it's not much fun and I think you play
Knight to 65 maybe also to get a bit of
yeah bit of the The Beatles track what I
thought is quite reasonable however is
taking in Queen f6 I think white is
better but it's not terrible and very
likely white has no clue about this line
Wow
I think what miles himself that he's
inventor of this line he played played
this continuation this also should be
not it shouldn't be a huge advantage for
white I don't think you can equalize
completely in the whole line but this
seam this also seems quite reasonable I
probably would would check this because
here I mean the the Queen train is
really harmless and you can for example
something like that is quite interesting
where you some people might say exchange
Queens or so I don't know I think black
it does not equalize fully but you can
definitely play the position I'm not
sure how often it is on the board really
I mean how often do people take here and
play neither three
and I don't really have a statistical
idea by the way I want to mention maybe
that it's not to your liking at all but
I want to mention that I think that this
is actually not that bad
what I would what I saw um I I saw a
relatively recent game in the in the
German Bundesliga
we were poor to play death with this
this was black against are not really ok
position and I think white players will
probably have no idea what you do so
maybe d5 is an option okay the next
question here by petrol side hello so he
has a couple of questions actually maybe
I should limited to one one per person
and to make it a little bit shorter he
says can black equalized in the eloquent
defense main lines and I don't think he
can and I think this is what what
patricide is referring to this is
probably the main line and I don't think
there is a clean way to equalize this
however I think you can definitely make
it work for black simply because of yeah
non symmetrical knowledge white has this
on the board maybe once a year in longer
time controls and if you have this like
every other game you can do I think
quite okay the lines that I would check
here to be honest with black I mean I
think there are lots of lines here there
are just a bit better for white so the
choice between lines that are a little
bit that a little bit better wise
actually rather white there is a recent
book by Alex a corner where koneff
recommends to play g6 I don't have that
book yet it is like released a week ago
or two weeks ago and I think that is one
of the more interesting tries but I
don't exactly know what his
recommendation is that always was
believed to be better for white and I
doubt that he can totally change this
assessment however I don't think that
right players know it all that well the
line that I have played a quite a bit as
Bishop g4 Bishop e2 and c6 I believe
this is also again better for white but
people won't know
I just my experience the most dangerous
lines are actually with castles where
they really know stuff very well or in
some 95 and this is really these kind of
things are very murky and if you know
them well I think you can do okay with
black what might be a little bit better
again but who knows this stuff okay the
second question here by petra site is
about the Slav
and it is about this about this line and
he asked why is this supposed to be bad
top gems as fine gold regardless as a
mistake but engines don't say clear
probably with it and it is played by
masters and yeah absolutely
wait Knight c3 I think you will probably
mean this position right the Musa a
little bit different that he that he
wrote here and I've got a printout of
the questions um I think you probably
refer refer to this position I hope I
hope you do so that my answer makes
sense the reason why this was regarded
as bad is traditionally this move
take take and Queen to b3 and it was
believed for our ages that black
basically now has to go back to c8
this is well quite clear that white
should be a little bit better even then
it's not much because the only are Tempe
up in a totally symmetrical and rather
slowish position but then it was found
out that black can actually play this
and make a pawn sacrifice out of this
this was even recommended in borås a
Brooks book the classical slab which was
I think quite sensational here because I
repeat is a top analyst and if he
recommends that for black it should be
something about this so I don't think
there is something fundamentally wrong
with this as long as you're willing with
Bishop f5 I mean as long as you're
willing to play this gambit line
honestly I'm not totally certain about
the current theoretical state I couldn't
get a clear picture by just looking at
it briefly but this is what black should
do then if he goes Bishop f5 should be
ready for that and you however have to
take into account that um why does not
need to do that white may also just play
Knight a3 and then you transpose to a
completely normal line if you it depends
a little bit on your repertoire here
what you want to do if you play let's
say a six laughs you can still play a
six and so on it's not yeah there's not
a huge upside of playing Bishop f5 here
I believe I don't know it depends a
little bit again on your overall
repertoire in particular if you I mean
if you want to take on c4 there that
make sense there to to maybe a look for
Bishop f5 as a sideline when I was
playing the Slav I was mostly playing a
six line so it didn't really matter all
that much what why did I was playing a
six here anyway okay the final question
here by the decide is about the cameras
attack in the shin discriminant he says
black hasn't violated any opening
principles but for some reason why does
allow to seemingly break some
playing g4 and gains an initiative today
the system may move I'm wondering what
could reasons make this strange-looking
pawn push playable um what what
concretely yeah and I mean one thing you
have to see you said Blacky did not
violate any opening principles objection
I think he did not right not like in a
bad way but black is not putting any
pawn on the fifth-ranked like you can
play a 45 which if you are on a meta
level is probably the better move on the
first move and prevent white from
playing D form make it more difficult
whatever so black is giving white some
leeway in niva in the center and also um
you can argue actually that a six is
early yeah you can say okay yeah well if
you go a six like in the night off you
keep an eye on the G Foursquare prevent
that so I'm not really buying that Black
has not violated any opening principles
I'm not saying it played bad moves don't
get me wrong but the black play of not
really I'm fighting for the center that
quickly is provocative in its own right
the main point of G form is actually a
disaster really important to understand
it's not just a king site demonstration
but rather she pushed this night away
there is no pressure on white center
anymore this is also why nowadays the
move h6 is almost regarded as the only
move that is that is okay for black
anything else is rather bad and what is
also important is that you have this
typical a recipe are hitting in the
center if they play on the flank and
center moves don't work 85 doesn't work
due to Bishop b5 check I don't want to
get into details but this is good for
white and d5 I think it's just yeah
really problematic I think back cause
probably uh because of taking yeah this
is what the engine gives I don't really
know why everybody five is bad I just
know nobody plays it but this looks this
looks pretty awful here so from the
black side you probably have to go h6
and then g4 was really kind of warranted
there are even crazier and crazier
positions where g4 is indeed valid okay
this video will get long okay okay the
next question is not really a question
all that much but rather you can
detailed post about sight lines against
Italian it's a very interesting post but
G hmm
I don't know g ng lay this is something
that is extremely interesting and that I
want to talk about in a separate video
so I have to I can actually this and
here I have to make a note I want to do
something separate about it's very
interesting and okay next question by
Thomas Harris heroin and he says the
reverse Grand Prix is considered to be
better than the actual Grand Prix attack
is this true and if so is there some
useful way to waste ammo so he's talking
about this 95 this one if I he's talking
about this this is a reverse Grand Prix
and indeed this has a quite reasonable
reputation and Grand Prix with white
does not have such a great reputation
why is that it's also a bit of a matter
of perspective yeah if you are white and
you play yeah you rather play for an
advantage with white then the girl Prix
is probably not so great because don't
get any however that set up with black
you have a little bit less of an
Bishan let's say and probably aren't
happy with less their who with equal or
something that is easy to play but now
the tempo widest no it's not white
smooth and the the reason why the
reverse grumpy sometimes has a better
reputation it's because whites moves may
now have drawbacks for example if y
place a normal move t3 then Bishop to
before it's quite useful now because
it's a pin now there is sorry I wanted
to draw this all the way to the King
it's now opinion so 95 is not an answer
if you imagine it is black smooth in the
Grand Prix and they play Bishop to b5
then the knight jump is the answer the
best move
they are not - in that case d 4 and D 3
is stopping that efy deserve ridding or
some yeah giving up on that idea then
this next point is if Y place a natural
looking move III then black has the
funky option d5 it looks odd but takes
takes it is actually interesting and
this is what I recommend for white by
the way now to play d3 and I think white
still has chances for small edge but
it's not something extraordinarily great
and now the question was what should Y
do with the wastage move is very useful
move for white and I have looked and I
would go III as mentioned I think black
is I think white is quite okay if black
now plays something outside d5 I think
at least you can be happy with the
position type it should play English
English opening I mean black can go g6
for example and you play 92 and then you
have the option if you want to go D 43 I
think that's something that an English
opening player should be okay with and
d5 as mentioned is not that terrible for
white I would yeah go for something like
this is what I recommended in my English
opening repertoire then that's my my
recommendation
and I think there are also ideas like an
idea 3 but I never looked at that and
I'm not quite sure if this is all that
helpful by the way a three to stop this
move is answered by g6 and then a three
years of relatively minor importance so
that would be it would be useful I've
seen Group B one but that is really a
kind of esoteric yeah bit and maybe
playable yeah it's such a slowish
position that it could be it could be
done in them by the way in the Grand
Prix just to complete the picture yeah
this is the Grand Prix and here the
issue is that if Bishop here then 94 is
fine and against Bishop c4 e6 9075 is
fine you can actually tribe with white
here to play some funky move like a
three for example yeah and say okay this
could be useful and then let's let's
black let's make like let's hope for
black making a move that then sounds
like d6 we should be five or so and this
is actually quite funky but I don't
really know what against a6 if this is
helping people have tried before word
okay we're getting into really really
funky stuff okay the next question can
you recommend something against a
Catalan for black I feel it's always
very pleasant for a white I think it's a
wonder what you want to say and often
again which results so something against
the Catalan yeah I do understand your
point first of all there could be two
ways to reach that could be here which
actually gives you some additional
options like not playing d5 c5 b should
before check our reasonable moves one we
can talk about the Catalan like this
which is probably what most people would
have and yeah now recommend something
for black iam honestly it's difficult
and I think and he says it's often a
game on two results meaning that
white is pushing for an advantage
without risking much and black is kind
of suffering I do agree this is often
the picture in many lines and I don't
have something fantastic to offer here
honestly it depends a little bit on what
kind of risk you are willing to take and
what position type you want to play in
general I think if you ask about what
the best lines are these are probably
the ones where black takes on c4 either
now one or move six and here you have
some some options that are indeed
interesting for example if you take here
there is the move Queen a4 check this is
however a relatively easy equality or
black you can play that be d7 or c6 9b
d7 as the main move and you should
equalize quite easily however this is
not very exciting it's very difficult to
get like a guaranteed excitement with
black I don't actually think it's
possible so this is very solid however
if white tries Bishop g2 and then you
have a couple of sharp or options moves
like a 6-1 knight c6 there's also the
really wacky line Bishop d7 and Bishop
c6 and now black actually can try to
Castle queenside and play some h5 stuff
this is sharp but probably object
objectively not great something to keep
in mind this is what I meant with
risking and this is definitely a risky 9
what I think is quite reasonable you can
try to keep many pieces on the board
with Bishop before check and now you
have a good choice between both Bishop
moves in both cases you can try a setup
there is some somewhat like this and
then maybe if build up a stone wall you
can also sometimes cannae - 5 the stone
wall is not unreasonable
and it is somewhat fighting it's not a
very clear-cut position for white where
you can like press easily I think it's
complicated but it's it's a matter of
taste there are people who downright
reject a stone war due to the to the
square weaknesses which I do kind of
understand if you if you if you I have
that opinion I don't think it's correct
but it's an understandable opinion you
can also play just the main line and
after Queen c2 which is normally done
try something interesting yeah you can
try b5 as an interesting move or b6 this
is something that I actually do not for
black quite a bit I think white doesn't
have all that much and it is quite
interesting if they play 95 then you can
take here and make a sacrifice out of it
I would look in those directions there
you can try to take and search for
something really sharp like what I am
but I said with B should be 76 again
it's probably better for white butter
shop you can play a long close game with
this I would really play the check and
then c6 don't play the closed without
the check 1 some mainline was something
like this here this has an edit benefit
in a way that instead of that b6 that
same is kind of interesting but not not
unsound let's say and it is still a move
that you could play against the strong
player who knows this things so it's a
good middle-of-the-road
approach that I think is quite
reasonable so it is difficult to
generate winning chances this is why the
Catalan is just great opening for what
ok the next question by let's go all the
way back is about the qg aim a fantasy
player in the qg a with III he says he
plays d5 but he wonders if Bishop e6 is
a reasonable surprise weapon
yeah I think that probably five should
be played if you if you want to avoid
the super standard stuffing which is of
course possible and then if five should
be played and thank you five is a decent
move we get we get this position which
is part of my efore keep it simple
repertoire via the the French exchange
and I think that White has some chances
to play for a slight pool but due to the
iqp there is some imbalance which makes
it also I think quite reasonable for
black to play so I wouldn't mind to play
that with both colors you want to put it
like that the move Bishop is six I think
is a reasonable and surprise weapon it's
probably not the best move ever let's
say but it has some surprise value and
will definitely irritate white players
and I don't think there is a super
clear-cut way for an advantage so it is
recommended in a book check chess
opening repertoire for rapid and blitz
by especially coffee and smashing golf
and I don't think they would recommend
something that is completely garbage
yeah so I think it's not the move that I
would play against let's say yeah a very
strong GM with good theoretical
knowledge but like in a blitz game yeah
why not I've tried it over to him and
reasonable or let's say very similar
lines and and the further question you
have a friend as a player
it says still so playing for an
advantage in the mainline Catalan should
be able to jump to that position because
we just talked about it he said he's
here and you know I think that white
always has chances for a slight slight
edge share with the with all kinds of
lines because I mean black players don't
know the theory perfectly it's just not
just doesn't happen and
I think the key to success as it is so
often in main lines is to be a little
bit flexible and very young most of the
time the black will not go be 6 but a 6
and then you have like a huge range of
lines you can take on c4 or in form I
would probably go 84 nowadays and try
for that and within this complex you
have various ideas or you can take and
in this position you also have some
moves you have Bishop d2 you have to
shoot g5 we should f4 most mostly and
all these are playable for sure and I
simply don't believe that black players
will know everything absolutely not
for example this line is something if
you play against a very strong opponent
you can just play Bishop g5 and
essentially say okay you're not winning
anymore this is something that is also
important to know where you have options
that can be very annoying against strong
players like like this here there's this
line where black either is worse or I
can play for complete equality but this
equality is so complete that leg will
never win so this is some line that I
always have in my repertoire just in
case if I need to draw against I don't
know somebody where draw is fine
yeah but it is some a by the way a
solution that you can easily win if they
don't know how the Equality is actually
proven so there are many options again I
would probably recommend to go a form to
be more complicated but I would just
very play two or three lines mix it up
and I think if you playing the Catalan
in on a good level you will be able to
win games without losing much which is
always a very good percentage play of
course okay I hope that helped um the
next question by HG Johnson how do
handle how do you handle a knight coming
to the e5 square in the qgd especially
early
on in the opening honestly I'm not
really aware that this happens so often
so um I would like an example honestly
because I'm not really I mean you say
let's say this is the qgd and then a
knight coming to e5 early on dude it
doesn't happen all that much there are
some lines in the exchange variation
where I can post up a Knight to e5 and
follow up with f4 but that usually means
that black has done something wrong so I
need an example basically because I'm
not really aware of lines where this
happens early on okay yeah just give me
some moves that is helpful okay here the
next question by Sean Adams is about the
English opening and assess he had issues
in the following line
93 and castle so b1 yeah this is part of
my repertoire the the English attract
the English repertoire on their own
chasuble and I do understand that you
say after c6 you came to the conclusion
that white is worse I don't think why
this verse because you can go if for
you can go before I think by the way I'm
just wondering did I actually recommend
you be one I'm kind of hmm I think I
think I played and didn't I do this I
think I played d3
I think I placed d3 in my c4 but I
should have look that up honestly the
point is the point is the following d3
is part of White's gender anyway yeah
and if now d6 root B 1 and you see six
ideas here would be 2 moves until you
can play a form and stop him from
playing d5 if you play will be 1 c6
before there might be d5 because there
is this very annoying move with temple
sometimes yeah so for example take take
a 5 there could be a no 94 and I had
this looks a little bit odd I think this
is the reason why I recommended d3 in
this position and I'd only seen drawback
him like after c6 you can play a form
and that fit fits into the oftentimes
into what white wants to do and you I
think avoid business with c6 and d5 that
way here if they go d5 I think you can
take and go if 5 I think I analyzed that
in my repertoire here would be one would
be highly undesirable because of the
early Bishop f5 I think you should
probably go DM d3m my memory serves me
correctly this is what I had in mind
in my English repertoire if that does
not fit into your your concept then yeah
I'm not quite sure what pawn structure
you're playing for them
usually with rupee 1 d3 is played at
some point so it should it should work
out I believe ok next question by Adam
Robinson he says he doesn't agree that
the reverse grünfeld is fine for black
he has won lots of games there with
white yeah welcome to the club I also
want
of games with wide them and what he's
talking about is based basically the
following I think the what what what I
have said in in an earlier video that
black could go for this as an option
against the white the white opening set
up and maybe I should have been more
precise I don't recommend to take now
I actually regard this as a reverse
Broomfield already yeah so maybe whether
terms were not quite clear I mean this
is not unplayable but I don't think it's
particularly comfortable for luck but
what you can do with black is e 6 C 4
and now take on C 4
this is actually what I was thinking of
of course white can take on C 5 and it's
not very exciting but I think black
should ultimately equalize him but he
has to know stuff but also white should
know some stuff so it's something that I
think you can play for keeping in mind
that not everybody with white plays d4
and knows everything so I completely
understand that you score heavily yeah I
also do score very heavily with white
but it is usually due to the fact that
black players have no clue but if they
if they have then it's I think black is
okay yeah the next question by
lieutenant moustache and he says he had
a question about Beauregard's Catalan in
the first video and this is something
that somehow I read but then did not
have on my piece of paper when I made
the video so I think it was about early
g3 early 93 I remember something like
that but yeah just again put the
question in again and I will look at it
it's somehow that kid that got lost yeah
maybe yeah I have a printout from others
saying I can't
maybe it's just a piece of paper went
astray or something okay and his new
question then he plays a car of Commerce
black and the sloth and his following
headless sloth book but God put on to
Beauregard Schiavone in kozlov book do
you think the mainland sloth is more
appropriate or than a six line for power
play and honesty so what he's saying is
if he should play this one
Asics um well if you have experience
with this already it's probably
interesting to learn how often you
actually get this on the board I have no
idea how often it is percentage-wise
um on a higher level almost nobody goes
into this anymore for white because it
is quite commonly believed that black is
okay and people play early III I mean
this is the mainline now by a mile on
the pro level so um I wonder how
relevant that is I don't know maybe on a
club level people play this a little bit
more what I'm getting at is you have to
know some stuff anyway like here white
other lines like Knight c3 d3 where you
cannot take and oftentimes actually a6
based approaches do make some sense for
example against III people quite often
play Bishop f5 Knight c3 a a6 which has
it's kind of a mixture of Shaban anko
and classical type or classical types
lot and if you have these lines in your
repertoire anyway then looking at a six
on move form
it's not such a huge thing yeah and I
don't know I have tried both and I think
it also just makes some sense to play
both just to be less predictable I don't
really have such a clear recommendation
about this what what I think should be
should be preferable my experience is
that in the Chapman anko people are less
booked up still even though it is now a
fairly fairly normal ish
Norman Esch line anything of the chip
and ankle you need a little bit less of
concrete theoretical knowledge in the
classical Slav like care there are some
really really deep line and cell with
Bishop f5 and 95 in particular I don't
know it's it's certainly okay for black
I mean as I said it has a good
reputation but it's quite a work low but
I think a six is a little bit less what
you are considered to play a six which
is actually quite okay no it's it's your
call what you want to do is submit this
is difficult and this is different to
the to the Carcano level okay the next
question is basically the same the
change of an ink oa6 interest Brian here
but he gets lost easily and did not find
good study material I don't think there
is a really recent book the Beauregard
book is also very old now
and I mean as probably still it's
probably usable but it is really old
now there is no recent book about it
there is just no recent book about the
the cheapening comb
I don't have a book recommendation what
you can do is certainly yes yeah use
databases and online resources to check
for recent games and see if somebody is
playing at playing it regularly back
then when I was studying this a little
bit more and played it regularly with
black the main problems here were a 4
and C 5 and but what I felt was still
interesting from like I mean I wasn't
really put off by anything in particular
I was just as usual switching around
openings yeah I was playing this most of
the time and then I started the news of
gogo project and then by practicing the
names of all I was going more in this
direction but I never had any particular
problem here I think if you study in the
chairmen anko I would definitely start
with the MU C 5 and a 4 this will be the
most dangerous moves available here well
I also have some I think g3 is also
quite interesting but a 4 and C 5 will
be done the moves that you check we
should check most most him and here
Brian also has a question about he says
he plays somewhat passively and he loses
many games due to that several of them I
had an advantage any advice to improve
on this this is a bit too general I mean
you have to see the games why exactly
this happens if you play too passively
and if you play too passively when you
have an advantage let's say I kind of
puzzle this together this way and you
have to maybe check what your advantage
consists of so sometimes you have an
advantage and you look at the engineer
value
says okay you're better and this however
can be a different kind of advantage
there can be something where you have to
find a dynamic resource where it's about
calculation and understanding let's see
how pieces work together and this is
something that can be proof of course by
yeah learning to calculate better and
get a better feel for the initiative it
can often help to study dynamic game 7
to be better at that or if you say go to
passively something that might happen to
us if you let's say you have material
now a pawn or whatever a piece for to
pawn some material and then you start to
be too protective of your material and
you turn to for more passive play to
defend your material this is something
that is more at attitude kind of thing
yeah sometimes you think okay now I've
done my job I've got the material now I
just have to defend and see em that I
converted and this is something that
like I just can't say in one sentence
you just have to stop it here if you've
got if your material now the main goal
that you should have is to use that
material to do some good yeah like the
pawn should control squares the piece
should be active and so on and only if
you don't see anything great that you
can do with your extra material you
should go to let's say trades and
simplify of course
it very much depends on the actual
position there that can be this kind of
advantage or this another kind of
advantage sometimes you also drift into
passive play not because if you want to
but simply you don't see a good
continuation there is one but you don't
see it and then you get then then let's
say you work your co-chair you are your
chess teacher says and you're playing to
passively and you didn't really do it on
purpose you just didn't see a good
opportunity and this can be improved
upon that being more thorough with
candidate moves yes so that you don't
miss an active possibility those will
often be checks captures something for
say
and it's really something that can be
improved if you just make this effort
every single position to check the
active moves first and only then go to
look at more passive moves yeah start
with the active moves that is some just
my general advice but it is more it can
be more concrete this advice if you give
somebody your games and like look look
through them that is some more third
picture the next question but Tommy
videos is good lines against the 4/9
with black where you can somehow play
for win and he's asking about this which
is part of my wide repertoire for keep
it simple with the move deform and
honestly there is nothing great that I
can do to play for when something like
really aggressive it's just not there
what I would do with black if I want to
win I mean if I really really really
must win the game I don't play one in
five it's just not the right move to do
that but if I am if I'm in a position
where I want to try it a little bit I
just don't want to make a simple draw I
want to be a bit more complicated I
would be I think looking in the
following directions I would still do
this and here I would rather either play
this line I think white is probably a
bit better there but it is a bit more
complicated yeah I gave some good advice
I think for white in my book but it's
not something there white wins or white
is like enormous ly better it is more
complicated and the other thing that you
can try is what I recommended for black
in my in the Khurana repertoire the the
petrov based fy5 a good one
this is let's say a bit of a gamble in
terms of playing for wit because there
are definitely continuations that are
just again very dry but it can also be
sharp or get sharp
if white doesn't know it or play
something that is kind of substandard
yeah it can be irritating moves I think
you have quite reasonable chances to do
something for example here it's still
simplified I know but I think they are a
little bit better off than the typical
main lines there if you absolutely want
to play e5 and ya want to go for win
against the faunas I would probably do
this not thinking that it is fantastic
yeah but it keeps more options and you
often can go with d6 keep more pieces on
the board and in the Spanish for Knights
let's go with them in the Spanish for
Knights my recommendation is Bishop c5
something that I had to look at years
ago in my video series on YouTube I but
then I analyzed it more formally 45
repertoire the Kohanim repertoire and I
think it's it's perfectly fine there are
also lines that are on the dry side but
this is just the nature of the opening
here
the only moves that I think that is even
more combative is Bishop to d6
yeah but this it's kind of I didn't want
to recommend it yeah in a in a
publication because it looks a bit too
hot for my taste I don't think it's bad
I've played it with black but I wanted a
more classical move and this is why I
went for Bishop c5 for that release that
is a reasonably new thing it was only
released in November last year so I
think this is perfectly fine the move 94
is difficult to play for win and
particularly if white only wants to make
a drawing bishop before it's the same
thing so this is a good
middle-of-the-road approach I think that
can be can be recommended okay so let's
see this video is already long and I
definitely don't want to go longer than
an hour actually happened how I was what
I wanted to go for let me see if I can I
think I can do some quick ones and then
put the other question in an additional
video the question here by God jeans Co
how about the black Medina gambit I
think I have addresses before yeah I
think this is actually important I think
this is a good move now so let's say
like this is a black Medina is it too
much of a garbage yeah well I don't
really believe it is a good opening and
probably best is to take it but so I
have probably showed that on video but
some years ago I studied it form for
black via a transposition and I found
that this is very simple very simple and
good reply it just is my quick fix
against black majima so if they take
here after if five black is fine I mean
not like you're not winning here but you
are fine and the position very often
will involve Queen trade which is
basically
the end of game yeah as the black medium
again but player usually wants to go for
checkmate
yeah so this is one thing they can also
do this after which you have a Kuro
where f3 is completely ridiculous you
can just play a normal move and be fine
yeah Bishop c4 they try then you can
play b5 there should be 3 I think he's 6
yeah now is 6 as f takes before it's
good for black and Knight takes Knight
takes is terrible because of the check
so honestly after c6 widest just versa
you can mainly equalize if it's very
precise but I don't exactly know how
this is going to happen so very simple
way to play against the black Medina
the next question is about the English
opening and it's about to this line my
special liner that I've played tons yeah
and he says hang gokula says it works
well if the Poland Plains g3 Bishop e3
e3 92 so he says that here he is doing
ok probably also thinking about castles
age 5 which is something that I've had
on the board like a million times
the Blitz games and where white is
fighting for equality it's very sharp
stuff now he says if the White Knight
goes to f3 and he plays III d4 I have
some problems any suggestion on how to
go against it this is a very valid
question and it is about to move order a
lot about move order so let's say this
is to move on at the very beginning if
they play g3 and Bishop c5 I think most
of the time people will actually play
III 92 it's kind of this early g3 Knight
c3 indicates that they are rather after
this but on a more general level if Y
plays g3 and you
the Bishop on c5 and then they decide to
play Knight a3 later yeah I think what
is the good setup is so following Bishop
g2 d6
and now why it's probably would go on
either 3f then my recommendation is to
do the following
a6 castles Bishop a7 and now I guess you
think are you referring to something
like u3 my general approach to this is
that black should strongly consider to
put a knight on to e7 and not to f6 the
idea is that if white plays d4 and most
of the time they will do that you can
actually take and later use the knight
on f5 I'm a little bit surprised that
the built in stock version so optimistic
for white I really don't think that what
is usually better here at all so let's
say 90s and now what I was thinking is
to go for a position like that where you
can put the knight on to a five later
rupee eight I think this is quite
reasonable white and it could be a
little bit better yeah but I don't think
it is something very substantial and it
is a rather complicated position I like
this a little bit more than putting the
knight on to f6 however this is a
completely normal position this is just
the normal position and definitely can
be played I would check 97 that's what I
think is some an interesting way to use
the fact that the knight is not yet
committed to there the next thing
however could be that you say well what
if they do this and this is very
interesting now playing with Bishop c5 I
always thought is terrible
but I'm not so sure anymore I think that
actually black might be able to play
that I recently saw that after e3 d6 d4
B should be form that blacks position is
actually quite playable here
I was surprised that looks a lot like
animals or for example after Bishop d2
or something Knight f6 sorry Knight f6
Quincy - this is not like an Enzo yeah
maybe it is actually an idea for white
to play a three in this position and
simply saying okay I'm not going to
allow you to go to before but even this
has been played yeah Black has played
stuff like a six d4 take take and back I
mean I know it looks odd but there have
been some games and legs
results weren't too terrible this is
food for thought you can however for
sure just play Knight f6 and go to a
mainline yeah another absolute recipe is
to start with this after Knight c3 do
this which is entirely different
this is Mohamed is playing for example
and only after g3 play with Bishop c5 so
that white is committed to g3 this is I
think quite a clever move okay I hope
that helps a little bit next question by
infinite flash chess unless
theoretically known set up against the
green felt yeah I guess we are talking
about the main move on him yeah the
green felt ever real realism and one
suggestions nearby atomic as a direct
reply to that is to play Bishop a4 based
stuff I agree this is interesting and
something that I do recommend playing
with Bishop f4 this is quite a bit
simpler than Queen b3 setups what I had
in my opening repertoire video from 2011
it's really quite a note on go Bishop f4
makes some sense or I think lines that
also could be tricky from like simply
because they are not well known
could be something like this III I know
it looks not very active but okay III
Bishop g7 and now moves like Queen to b3
or an idea 3 Bishop d2 this could be
interesting I don't think that black
players would have lots of knowledge
there for example after Queen b3 they
not saying they have to play your six
but it is it is probably the best move
and if they don't know this all that
well they might play c6 or something and
white is quite comfortable
I think specializing in lines like that
can be quite um quite rewarding in
particular if you don't play lots of
opponents that prepare heavily yeah
simply if they have to solve that over
the board is not easy for example there
is stuff like a six Queen to a 3 and
this will irritate black absolutely with
every tip like he's fine but play it
it's not not so simple so there are some
line that's lines that are not very
theoretical so example also here this is
a completely non theoretical line that
can also be played Knight to c3 Bishop
e2 castles and then you just play a game
I mean black equalizes but he he does so
in the Greenfeld anyway okay so um yeah
the next question is a bit too too long
Oh
the next question is interesting
and as this one by lieutenant moustache
again yeah the Catalan question yeah
please please if you phrase that again
yeah the Catalan was g3 the bolo gun
repertoire move orders just put it in
again
I'm sorry enough that you have to do
that but I'm happy to answer them mmm
this is an interesting and interesting
more general question about or by Zak
Soto what asks some questions you have
to be able to answer if you have
thoroughly analyzed a position in the
opening that's a really interesting
question
I'm not sure like if I can answer that
if you have thoroughly analyzed the
position in the opening I think if you
would look at an opening and you think
about adopting it playing it what you
should be able to answer is what is the
main line what are the main lines why
are they in the main lines where are
some other lines not that good
ideally if you really want to know
what's going on it is fantastic
if you do understand how this opening
evolved over time sometimes there's a
real history a little rich story of the
whole thing they they stride a certain
move order then they refined it then
they found out that a certain line
doesn't work and you have replace it you
improve on it and this is how lines
evolve if you get to this depth of
understanding you really have profound
knowledge of the opening but you also
should probably know and it's very
helpful to know is who are the experts
ideally you are the expert but you have
to work hard on that but if you really
are the experts if you have found out
who are the driving forces behind some
lines then you can study the games and
you can sometimes just copy what they do
is enormously helpful or you can
sometimes just pick up some specific
middle game ideas which is also super
helpful so these are some things that
are very useful to do also in many cases
openings deal a lot with move borders
you should be able to understand the
move orders yeah for example I've had I
read and know people who really let's
say we can play the Queen's Gambit with
any color and they're not really aware
that what are the differences between
those two modes let's say and there are
quite huge and in many cases and if you
really have understood the whole thing
let's say then you can probably tell
why would white play 93 what is the
intention behind the move where Knight
f3 what are the ups and downs or what is
the the pros and cons of Knight f3
compared to 93 if you let say if you can
be lets say woken up at night 3 a.m. in
the morning and put out in front of an
audience and explain that if you can't
do that you really have never understood
the opening well ok now is there
something that I can answer quickly
and it's very sophisticated to question
about the Spanish and this okay I should
probably make a separate video there and
address the open points there's some
really interesting ones but it's
difficult to get all into into one video
so this is already one hour long I hope
you enjoyed it if you have new questions
and I think you probably will have put
them right here as comments to that
video yeah and I will definitely check
it for the next for the next episode
that probably will be out in roughly one
week thanks a lot for watching